قسمت دراسه المرضى المنسيون ضعيفي المناعه
الى فئتين الاولى اضطراب العوز المناعي
الاولاني وينتج عن عيوب في تطور الجهاز
المناعي ويظهر هذا النوع لدى الاطفال
غالبا ينتشروا اكثر في المناطق التي ترتفع
فيها معدلات زواج الاقارب لذلك يزيد ب 20
مره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
اما العوز المناعي الثانوي يظهر عندما
تثبت عوامل خارجيه الجهاز المناعي ووظيفته
الطبيعيه منها مرض السرطان وعلاجاته
وامراض الكلى المزمنه وفيروس الايدز لهذا
يتزايد عدد مرضى السرطان في بلدان الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
بمعدلات مقلقه في ظل توقعات بتضاعف عددهم
تقريبا بحلول 2030 كما يقدر الاتحاد
الدولي للسكري ان اكثر من 70 مليون شخص في
المنطقه مصابون بالسكري وهو اعلى عدى
الانتشار لهذا المرض في العالم كما يؤثر
الفشل الكلوي على 100
و87.000 شخص تقريبا في مختلف بلدان
المنطقه ويعد الذين خضعوا لعمليات زرع
اعضاء من اكثر فئات المرضى ضعي في المناعه
عرضه للخطر اما بالنسبه لانتشار فيروس نقص
المناعه البشريه
فتعدوا منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
من مناطق العالم القليله التي تشهد زياده
سريعه في الاصابات بهذا الفايروس حيث
ازدادت بنسبه 31% منذ عام 2001